[Music]
okay as Tom and Jen we're back at the MC
again we just saw Johnny English strikes
again yeah which were at the very bottom
of the barrel for this month I mean and
it was the same guy who plays with mr.
bean what that guy's no yeah I'd ever
seen back in oh yeah
anyway it was kind of a spoof on James
Bond I'd probably say maybe from the era
of from Thunder ball yeah Roger more
like a Roger Moore era of James Bond
flick with kind of more modern like the
film was pretty modern really you know
that the story was very similar to
Spectre that's what I that's what I
thought they were parenting yeah like
the way the plot was right we're a big
tech is becoming a threat to the nation
states which kind of coming true today
you know they're having problems with
Google and everything but I would say I
enjoy the movie wasn't bad it's actually
quite funny it's like yeah it's funny
and like a British kind of way we're not
super zany herbs it's tough it's more
like a sarcastic yeah and it's kind of
like I haven't I don't think I saw the
first one if I did I don't really
remember it I was like - Rowan Atkinson
I'm like mr. bean I like to black get
her back in the day
he's a funny guy he's like good he's a
good physical comedian
yeah and he's really good at like cringe
humor where he is just like so such an
embarrassing person that you kind of
like yeah like yeah so this is kind of
like what it would be like if James Bond
was a clueless dork yeah he was super
slick and yet somehow still ended up
going yeah ass-backwards into everything
working out for him yeah
like would get everything done by
accident yeah but like like I said the
funniest thing about it is he has no
idea like how how idiotic and like yeah
I think the movie was actually a pretty
traditional movie almost like a
throwback it actually felt like I was
watching something from the nineties
which I think that might have been a
good thing because they're trying to be
like an old-school James Bond movie but
they still tried to keep it fresh enough
to wear you know a modern audience could
watch it yeah there's a lot of tropes
from Bond if you're a Bond fan you might
enjoy it well I have you don't mind
Sagan Mary yeah but in a way it's also
kind of honoring it in certain in a
certain way because they did make a
Johnny English kind of a likeable guy
when he got fired he felt bad and then
he kinda did come back it was kind of
trying for the of the idiotic man
triumph of the IDIA if we didn't ever
name it common man it was funny cuz uh
next to me it was like they brought in
some kids they were mentally handicapped
I guess yeah and from two Street and
they didn't understand the humor but the
kid next to me was just like Johnny
English and it's just the same I was
like chill out man alright he's very
excited about it and I guess either I
don't know maybe thought you just maybe
get mad man he thought you're making fun
of it I don't know but would this be a
movie that I would go pay to see Bry not
cry yeah I probably actually didn't even
know this was playing and then we're
kind of like scrolling through and he's
like oh what's that I was like another
one of these out because I've been
seeing a mr. bean movie in a long time I
don't think I saw the first train I
think I would have joined this but I
would have enjoyed this movie more
watching at home drunk yeah yeah
especially if I was able to stand up and
go I suppose to laugh at it
is sitting at home in your room yeah
because it is like it is very funny like
I liked a lot of the humor it is nothing
unexpected really like it's very
traditional along a traditional British
comedy and it's almost kind of like a
traditional spoof quick I mean you know
there's a lot of like [ __ ] from airplane
and then the old was it like police
academy almost like that it was gonna
like like that but I'd like to that's
like not only do they usually the same
kind of plot inspector with like the
ticket like trying to take over the
world salty air and stuff but they also
had that thing with the newer Daniel
Craig James Bond yeah where it was kind
of like old school feeling field agents
versus technology yes so they kind of
played that up a lot too because you
know Johnny English he had been retired
many years ago and so he was very old
school yeah they're bringing him back
retire phone he didn't that's why I said
Roger Moore yes he's kind of more like a
Roger Moore era right like cutting into
the bottom right and so it's like a
fidgeter when he's still kind of worked
but only by accident yeah you know but
it wasn't a bad movie yeah the only
thing I can say about it is those I
probably wouldn't pay full price to yeah
like you said I I saw the Holloway a
drink yeah yeah right that their drunken
just and you know I like James Bond to
like Mission Impossible and I enjoyed
this I didn't think it was goofing on it
to the point to where it was an insult
yeah I think it was kind of paying
homage no no it was it was trying to
actually kind of be the genre in a jokey
way yeah all right let's go we heard
Lincoln call quits I think we've covered
it yeah we did
you
okay so we're back at it again we're at
AMC we just got done seeing one called
hunter-killer which I would probably
describe is kind of like a military
disaster movie
you know those disaster movies you've
got people in control rooms and they're
all yelling and screaming because some
Bad's going on and even though there are
thousands of miles apart or somehow some
kind of a relationship between them it
was a movie like that kind of take a Tom
Clancy flick and throw it throw it in
with a disaster movie and maybe like
Mission Impossible and that's what you
got it's got the guy who played Leonidas
from 300 was in it he was like a
submarine commander Gary Oldman was in
it he played some kind of high-ranking
naval guy yeah and it's about uh about
uh what do you call it a coup happening
in Russia and the United States gets
mixed up in it in the second or third
world war almost kicks off lots of lots
of fake military accuracy lots of
[Music]
military jingo that's the only civilians
use lots of shots of a bunch of
different weapon systems in the same
frame like you know you like it you'll
have a frame with like two submarines in
it and a bunch of flying torpedos entire
fleets of ships guys they called special
operators which I don't know what a
special operator is they never did name
I guess that was that's just something
civilians use I guess they were a SEAL
team but when a bad flick Factory was
alright it was just it gets it gets old
I thought after a while you know they're
trying to keep you way up here in terms
of tension and it's like that for about
two hours after about an hour into it
you started getting kind of sleepy what
do you think um I didn't mind it it
reminded me very much of like
and 80s or early 90s kind of cold war
type thriller like yeah we're in October
or something like along those lines yeah
it didn't like it wasn't a fantastic
movie but it was it wasn't bad thing
like that you know it did actually move
along the plot moved along and there was
like all kinds of setbacks and you're
like yeah it felt like a disaster movie
it really did yeah it really had a lot
of that to it and I thought it was kind
of cool because most of it was set you
know inside a submarine so it's like you
have that claustrophobia issue you know
I don't know I thought it was pretty
entertaining for what it was it's just
like I'm surprised like a standard 80s
action yeah it was it was like a
throwback the form the format the format
was very very traditional yeah it was a
traditional language which actually that
was the right call that was the right
action to go in actually for me I'm
surprised that you liked it for me being
ex-military I see these kind of movies
and I'm and I kind of get bored with
them like I said in fall asleep I wasn't
bored it's like it kept me interested
through the whole running time yeah like
you know what I want to see it again
right by it now it's like you know it
was an entertaining to draw to draw back
with these kind of movies where they're
trying to have realism and then is that
having military experience you know that
actual military situations are not this
exciting yeah well that's why I like a
lot of notes here movies I like fancy I
like oh yeah I don't like it I don't
like it to try and sell itself you know
I mean like expenditures expendable is
just pure oxygen a lot of fun you know
like I said you know movie in real life
is right but when you start getting into
where they're trying to do realism like
with some of the Tom Clancy movies to me
it doesn't really the tone kind of
doesn't really work well for me well but
you know like I said it wasn't a bad
movie
I think they did I think they did a good
job on it
I think the acting was good just for me
I just kind of get tired of these movies
yeah it's not like anything new it's not
original it's nothing you haven't seen
before like I said especially if you
like 80s action movies earlier that's
type action movies it's very much like
that it's formatted very much like that
like I said the acting is good it was
interesting it kept me entertained it
was so you know you could do worse I
actually think that the movie will
probably do this movie would probably do
okay I think you know yeah I actually
saw like reviews that like I don't rate
reviews but I saw like the percentages
and the percentage is like half and half
I haven't like yeah it's all right which
is book which is about what we're saying
there's a market for these movies though
you looked at the audience in the
artists today was a lot of old guys yeah
old retired guys fat guys yeah yes they
love this [ __ ]
all right so wittekop
[Music]
okay should be good all right so it's
our third movie of the week yeah AMC
Suns a list prog-rock day we saw small
footages yeah tomorrow tomorrow actually
we're gonna find out Suspiria Snoop lion
Sochi I was really crabby about that
where they think Suspiria but I've heard
this is really good at kicks out so
we're gonna go see that tomorrow but
this is the last one of this week like I
said we're kind of getting to the bottom
like a lot of the movies that we had to
see like in October like I've been
playing for a while and actually even
though times like I was the last one so
yeah I love it it's just like there's
like village of friendly yetis no they
live up in this way like high up in this
mountain and they don't know that humans
exist yes you have this kind of like
this hokey religion that kept them you
know on the top of this mountain and not
believing this kind of stuff and then
first I kind of thought it was gonna be
kind of a one of the that bad story of
kind of like hey you know question
religion like that's all right whatever
it turns out later on there's like a
twist to it the guys that are practicing
their preaching this religion knew they
knew that none of this stuff was true
and it was there was a means of
self-defense because Millennia's before
there had been they had almost got a
wiped out by the human by the human so
they were trying to say we yeah did not
let anybody know that right so they were
believing in a falsehood for their own
advantage for their own protection right
but to make a long story short now
there's a human involved in this and
he's like a nature guy who owns a
Nature's Way it's Steve Irwin time yeah
either had a British or Australian
accent I couldn't tell exactly what it
was trying to be but yeah yeah so he's
the funny trying to get good ratings
yeah and so like one of the said that
was very funny in that whole aspect of
it so one of the yetis whose name is
Miko he's like the main character and he
sees a human a small foot ruff and of
course nobody the village believes him
they don't
they exist and then there's like this
whole little contingent of like
conspiracy theory like people that he
befriends that believe in the small foot
and there's this whole conflict between
them in the village and it's just it
like I said that the writing of it was
really cute
it's just a really good it was a really
good story they even had like a couple
of funny like if you know anything about
creationism or about any of the old kind
of yeah there's no all thanks to that
there was callbacks to that it's like oh
it's mammoths all the way down instead
of turtles all the way down the end I
mean if what are they standing on you
know if the earth is being held by
pillars what are the pillars there right
exactly that kind of stuff so there was
a lot of that kind of little sneaky
little things in there plus I have to
say the animation was beautiful yeah oh
by the way this is a musical it is
there's it's not like you know a tall
thing is it beautiful but there's like
three or four songs yeah and the songs
are pretty cool one of them was to to
the to the tune of under pressure yeah
and the one that the the head of the
village like this stone keeper who has
like this broom yeah he says he had a
really good I think it was called let it
live
yeah where he was just telling me like
show ya like why the religion was the
way when he was like showing me go the
truth about it it was all red and
everything but yeah it's like this I
actually really like this a lot like for
a kids movie was entertaining I thought
it was delightful it was really
entertaining
like I said animation gorgeous it was
especially really nice on the big screen
like really I'm glad but that we
actually saw it in the big screens and
he's like really nice-looking yeah but
yeah just than that there's a new
overlord poster and we're trying to talk
away in the unison posters and figures I
know we're trying to talk to you
yeah I put that into my did you see
every storm I'm still okay I wish they
sold those shirts right there look it's
got a MCM a sir okay show the show the
show the audience that shirt that cream
- sure this is AMC on the side come
we wish you guys would sell those yeah
they just told me to throw it on yeah I
want one of those with the AMC on the
side
[Music]